l'explosion du boeing de la panam en
écosse hier soir près de 280 victime
très vraisemblablement un attentat deux
pistes les extrémistes palestiniens
d'abou nidal où une mystérieuse
organisation iranienne
le chômage en baisse pendant les deux
derniers mois 1,9 pour cent de
demandeurs d'emploi en moins
le ministre du travail jean pierre
soisson invité du journal pari passu
frau malgré l'opposition de la
commission bruxelles les 12 milliards de
dhs est ce que la régie renault épongé
par l'état afghanistan la guerre oubliée
les moudjahidine à l'assaut des villes
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
tinguely à beaubourg une vaste
rétrospective consacrée à paris au
sculpteur suisse est assez drôle de
machine
madame monsieur bonsoir l'horreur
l'horreur hier soir à l'aéroport de new
york quand les parents les amis ont
appris que les 258 personnes qui avaient
embarqué une heure plus tôt à l'aéroport
de londres sur le vol panam 103 étaient
tous morts l'horreur toute la nuit toute
la journée à lockerbie
cette paisible bourgade écossaise connu
jusque là pour son marché aux moutons
sur laquelle le boeing 747 7 écrasé hier
à 20h30
dix sept personnes au moins ils sont
mortes philippe harrouard vous le voyez
on dirait une scène deux bombardements
l'avion là donc percuté 40 maisons ont
brûlé et l'avion s'est ensuite écrasé
sur cette route exactement essaimant des
débris partout à la ronde sur plus de 20
km et dans la ville de lockerbie
il n'y a pas un n'est ce pas une maison
pas à jardin qui n'est des débris de cet
avion
ces maisons calcinées à des trois étages
la recherche de ses habitants qui ont
été tués alors
l'art est tranquille à la maison a duré
toute la journée ce qui m'a frappé le
court aujourd'hui à lockerbie
c'est le silence des genres on ose à
peine parler qui murmurent il n'y a ni
révolte ni affolement d une immense
tristesse un grand étonnement comme si
on ne prenait pas encore conscience de
la tragédie qui s'est déroulée cet homme
nous parle de la gigantesque boule de ce
qu'il a vu s'abattre sur sa ville c'est
comme si le ciel plan b dit il
incroyable n'avais jamais vu cela depuis
la guerre et puis il y a le trou
cet énorme cratère là où le gros du
boeing s'est écrasé près du cours de
golf les corps des 2 158 passagers
disséminés sur la colline sont peu à peu
récupéré par les soldats qui les
conduisent dans une chapelle ardente à
la mairie cette bouleversante ces vies
brisées
les enquêteurs devront tenir compte de
tout du moindre détail pour déterminer
les circonstances de cet accident
c'est difficile de dire quoi que ce soit
j'adresse simplement mes sincères
condoléances à tous les habitants de
lockerbie
depuis ce matin à l'ocbn
en effet des patrons marocains prix
énorme on essaie de reprendre contact
avec la réalité impossible à bord de
l'avion américain
beaucoup de militaires américains qui
avaient embarqué à francfort et 38
étudiants de l'université de
l'université syracuse de new york où
étaient aussitôt organisé une veillée
funèbre les étudiants revenait d'un
premier semestre d'études en europe
allait report qu'elle dit les parents
éplorés s'en sont pris parfois à la
presse trop avides de leur douleur parmi
les membres de l'équipage
il y avait quatre français les deux
boîtes noires du 747 ont été retrouvés
dans l'après midi
on croit de moins en moins à un accident
technique puisque jusqu'à la catastrophe
l'équipage n'a rien signalé d'anormal au
contrôleur aérien et que l'appareil
avait été entièrement révisée il y a
quinze jours
l'enquète vient d'être confiée à la
section antiterroriste de scotland yard
car l'attentât et bien l'hypothèse la
plus probable bernard benyamin
oui c'est vrai que 6000 ya ce soir un
certain nombre d'indicés disons qu'ils
font pencher vers la thèse de l'attentât
il ya une revendication nous allons y
revient tout à l'heure il ya surtout une
lettre une lettre adressée à tous les
diplomates américains que nous allons
voir tout de suite daté du 5 décembre et
qui précise qu'une action terroriste
pourrait être tenté contre un avion de
la panam allant de francfort à new york
et ce avant la fin de l'année donc ça
c'est une première piste y en a une
autre qui serait plutôt iranienne
semble-t-il c'est ça en gros disons deux
pistes une piste iranienne une piste
disons palestino syrienne la piste
iranienne d'abord qui s'appuie sur une
revendication de l'attentât faite à
londres m par les gardiens de la
révolution islamique
pour se venger de la destruction de leur
bus iranien en juillet dernier disons
tout de suite que cette piste ne paraît
pas très sérieuse
pour un certain nombre de raisons la
plus importante étant que toute la
politique étrangère iranienne est
actuellement concentrée sur une reprise
de ses relations avec les pays
occidentaux et qu'un démenti sans appel
nous est parvenu cet après-midi de
téhéran par la bouche du premier
ministre iranien le chef de file des
radicaux qui a même exprimé ses regrets
pour l'attentât et présenté ses
condoléances aux familles des victimes
piste improbable donc mais toujours
possible puisque aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'organisations shit liés
directement ou indirectement à téhéran
sont toujours en activité
deuxième piste christine vous le disiez
la piste palestino syrienne deux indices
en notre possession ce soir il y un mois
et demi à francfort d'abord une cache
d'armes a été découverte elle
appartenait à un groupe palestinien
prosyriens dissidents de l'ol paie
deuxième indice selon une chaîne de
télévision américaine un homme se
réclamant de l'organisation d'abou nidal
a prévenu au début du mois l'ambassade
américaine d'helsinki de l'imminence de
l'attentât
abou nidal lui aussi opposé à yasser
arafat
condamné à mort par le lp prosyriens
toutes ces organisations vous l'avez
compris sont violemment opposé au
rapprochement actuel entre les etats
unis l olp et c'est vrai que depuis
l'ouverture des discussions entre
palestiniens et américains
on craignait un tel attentat mais je
crois christine ce soir qu'au delà de
ces pistes il faut souligner une
nouvelle fois que tout ceci n'est
qu'hypothèse la seule chose tangible que
nous ayons pour le moment pour
accréditer la thèse de l'attentât
c'est le silence radio observé par le
pilote avant la catastrophe
oui quels que soient les auteurs de
l'attentât le problème qui préoccupe les
responsables de la sécurité aérienne
renforcer ce soir dans tous les grands
aéroports
c'est bien sûr de savoir comment on s'y
est pris beaucoup de passagers était en
effet parti de france à bord d'un boeing
727 pour transiter ait changé d'appareil
à londres où sont montées d'autres
voyageurs philippe rochot est à
francfort pascal deschamps à londres
à l'aéroport niçois on ne veut rien dire
mais on s'en pose cependant une question
et non des moindres s'il s'agit bien
d'un attentat
comment un engin explosif at il pu se
trouvaient à bord de l'appareil qui a
décollé d'ici hier soir dans l'hypothèse
la plus vraisemblable
la bombe aurait été embarqué à francfort
arrivé à londres les passagers en
changer d'avion leurs bagages les ont
suivis transférés dans des containers
comme ceux ci d'un appareil à l'autre
il suffisait alors qu'un de ses
passagers s'éclipse et laisse son bagage
piégé poursuivre sa route
oui c'est possible
il y à des contrôles prévus ils peuvent
ne pas être strictement appliquée
l'ordinateur peut tomber en panne
le personnel peut être surchargé en
cette période on est parfois moins
vigilants
enfin cela me paraît tout de même
improbable une hypothèse d'autant plus
tentante que les enquêteurs
s'intéressent de très près depuis hier
au témoignage d'une passagère qui leur a
signalé
l'étrange comportement d'un autre
passager monté à francfort il avait le
type arabe
je ne peux pas dire de quel pays ils
venaient mais il avait l'air contrarié
il me regardait il regardait par terre
et regarder tout le monde mais il
cherchait à éviter le regard des
policiers
il paraissait vraiment très agité par la
voix de leur ministre des transports les
autorités britanniques se refuse à toute
spéculation
paul shannon a promis un rapport
préliminaire sur la catastrophe dans les
quinze jours avant de quitter londres
avant le crash sur la commune de
lockerbie le tiers des passagers du 747
avait embarqué dans un autre avion un
appareil qui venait de francfort une
trentaine de militaires américains
appartenant aux deux cent cinquante
mille soldats stationnés en allemagne
fédérale avait embarqué ici avec
d'autres passagers américains pour aller
passer noël en famille aux états unis
pas de contrôles exceptionnels à
francfort car déjà les forces de
sécurité sont en état d' alerte maximum
depuis l'attentât revendiqué par le
groupe abou nidal en juin 85 devant les
guichets des dalles trois personnes
avaient trouvé la mort l'hypothèse la
plus plausible celle du sac en transit à
francfort enregistré dans un pays où les
contrôles sont moins sévères qu'ici
le transit d'un colis piégé restent le
maillon faible de la chaîne de sécurité
qui protègent les passagers un commando
suicide a même très bien pu voyager sur
la panam avec sa banque dans la soute
certains bagages sont testés par des
chiens pour y trouver la drogue mais
toutes les valises ne subissent pas le
test des rayons alerte à la bombe
cet après midi à bord d'un appareil de
la british airways reliant koweït à
londres il a été détourné sur rome deux
millions cinq cent trente sept mille
cent demandeurs d'emploi en france en
novembre le chômage vous le voyez
continue de baisser puisque les chiffres
annoncés ce soir sont à la fois ceux du
mois de novembre et du mois d'octobre
qui n'avaient pas pu être calculée pour
cause de grève des postes
monsieur soissons bonsoir vous êtes les
ministres du travail plutôt un ministre
heureux ce soir alors oui parce que pour
la quatrième fois consécutive le chômage
baisse en france leschi vous les avez
rappelé le nombre de chômeurs a diminué
au cours du mois de novembre de près de
30000 et au cours des trois derniers
mois le nombre de chômeurs a diminué de
plus de 100000 nous pouvons dès lors
parler d'une modification de tendance et
on peut bien évidemment analyser les
raisons de cette modification de temps
dans j'en vois deux
d'abord la croissance beaucoup plus
forte beaucoup plus importante que prévu
l'économie française retrouve la forme
et c'est la raison majeure du recul du
chômage nous allons terminer l'année
avec un taux de croissance de 3 et demi
pour cent et c'est la performance la
plus forte depuis 1976 nous allons
également créer cette année près de 170
mille emplois et cette croissance très
forte se retrouvent dans les
statistiques du chômage que vous non de
publier une seule si vous le voulez bien
les offres d'emploi déposées par les
entreprises de tous les de tous les
départements petites et moyennes dans
les agences des passes pour le mois de
novembre
cinquante mille ce qui veut dire qu'il
ya
signe de la vitalité retrouvée de notre
économie et c'est incontestablement la
première raison la deuxième la deuxième
raison c'est sans doute également la
mise en oeuvre des mesures que le
gouvernement a arrêté au cours du
printemps et au cours de l'été puisque
nous avons pour le mois de novembre
et c'est les chiffres qu'il indique 170
mille demandeurs d'emploi soit qu'il
s'agisse de jeux dans la recherche d'un
premier emploi soit qu'il s'agisse
d'adultes au chômage qui ont commencé un
stage de formation le ministre
cette reprise de la croissance et le
traitement social est ce que c'est une
heureuse conjonction mais momentanée ou
est ce que c'est une tendance durable en
clair est-ce que le chômage va baisser
en 89 et de combien si vous pouvez le
dire je peux pas vous dire de combien il
baissera je ne suis pas certain que la
tendance actuelle se confirme et il faut
permettez-moi de le dire ce soir se
garder de tout optimisme parce que la
croissance l'année prochaine peut-être
moins forte et parce que d'autres
phénomènes peuvent jouer notamment les
entrées sur le marché du travail les
jeunes à la recherche d'un premier
travail ou bien les femmes les femmes
adultes qui ne s'était pas être dans une
agence pour l'emploi qui peuvent le
faire dès l'instant qu'elle voit la
situation s'améliorait donc nous ne
sommes pas certain du tout que la
tendance actuelle peu puisse se
poursuivre
ce que nous savons simplement maintenant
c'est que l'année 88 sera une bonne
année et nous allons vers une croissance
zéro du chômage pour 88 deux graphes de
graff prudence pour 89 oui alors donc en
observant cette prudence et avant de
poursuivre je vous propose de voir
monsieur soissons comment sur le terrain
au delà donc du plan de l'emploi que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
l'initiative privée peut prendre le
relais c'est ce que maryse manua
constaté à saint-etienne
la mine est une vieille histoire c'est
une histoire si on a choisi ce site
c'est justement pour peta pour des
raisons sentimentales puisque je supplie
de mineurs mais aussi parce que nous
tenions absolument à ce que ça se
transforme pas en une zone déserte et
que ces bâtiments qui ont une histoire
un passé industriel revivent d'une autre
manière pour redonner vie à ces usines
abandonnées
il a choisi d'y amener les sans emploi
de la région dans un seul but leur
trouver du travail après leur passage
ici
80 % des chômeurs que roger bonneviale
accueil vont ils parvenir jeunes sans
formation fin de droits trop âgés tous
ont retrouvé leurs marques comme cet
ancien ouvrier de manufrance vous a
versé pendant trois ans à fourier c'est
pas évident
et puis bon je fais un stage d'un
donneur sa part la suisse et au civil
j'ai une promesse d'embauché à partir de
le miracle tient à la méthode dès
l'entrée une pointeuse rappelle les lois
du travail à ceux qui l'ont oublié sur
chaque machine on travaille en couple la
tête blanche c'est un retraité qui
offrent bénévolement son savoir faire
aux plus jeunes un peu pour moi est un
peu pour les rencontres les eaux si les
formateurs ne sont pas rémunérés les
stagiaires leçon aux mig en général ils
ont un contrat de travail et surtout ils
exécutent de vraies commandes dans le
bâtiment les ouvriers travaillent pour
des particuliers en mécanique
ils sous-traitent pour des entreprises
de la région bref chaque équipe
fonctionne ici comme une entreprise
on parle d'ailleurs productivité dès le
3ème mans il s'agit pas de créer des
illusions
c'est pas un centre social où on
apprendrait la poterie on part toujours
de l'expérience de l'epr s'ils veulent
par exemple apprendre la plâtrerie
peinture alors qu'ils avaient une
expérience de deux ans avec aline
général ont dit non vous allez voir leur
sport que j'allais voir l'éducation
nationale michel on pas faire ferme sur
la méthode
roger bonneviale à réinsérer près de 200
chômeurs en quatre ans rançon du succès
usinor réclame ses services en lorraine
mais il aura du mal à quitter
saint-etienne monsieur soissons c'est
celle à venir - d'état plus
d'initiatives à la base l'avenir c'est
incontestablement les initiatives
locales pôle emploi je ne crois pas un
instant que l'on puisse régler le
problème du chômage par des décisions
prises à paris dans un ministère c'est
impossible et donc tout ce qui peut être
fait à la base pour permettre le
développement de telle initiative doit
être doit être réalisé votre reportage
est tout à fait étonnant parce que qu'il
s'agit d'une d'une association qu'il
s'agisse d'une entreprise d'insertion
qu'il s'agisse de toutes les initiatives
locales je suis persuadé que comme aux
états unis
finalement une partie je dis pas tout
une partie du problème du chômage sera
ainsi réglé j'ajoute que des problèmes
de réinsertion sont des problèmes
majeurs et parce que nous avons de plus
en plus de chômeurs de longue durée qui
ont perdu tout habitudes de travail avec
un noyau dur menacé de d'exclusion
sociale est l'une des idées majeures qui
va tout à fait dans dans le reportage
que vous venez de montrer qu'ils en
outre elle est l'illustration parfaite
du plan pour l'emploi du gouvernement
c'est de prendre les dépenses passives
d'indemnisation du chômage et de les
transformer en des mesures actives de
réinsertion des chômeurs l'entreprise
c'est un peu ce que l'exemple
saint-etienne viennent de nous montrer
et donc ça pourrait être une des
orientations que vous pourriez suivre à
l'avenir absolument plusieurs
orientations très simple la priorité au
traitement économique du chômage
si on veut moins de chômage et plus
d'emploi il faut des entreprises plus
prospères et donc allégée des charges
des entreprises leur permettre de créer
des emplois
c'est la première priorité la deuxième
priorité c'est le développement local
laissé faire les initiatives comme
celles que vous avez montré et attendre
du terrain beaucoup plus que nous ne
pourrions le le décider à paris et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on crée un fonds
d aide aux initiatives locales pour
l'emploi et je pense que saint-etienne
j'en avais d'ailleurs par les
responsables lorsque j'étais allé dans
cette ville il ya quinze jours
saint-etienne pourra bénéficier d'un tel
fonds et la troisième c'est une
formation professionnelle qui soit mieux
adapté aux besoins des entreprises c'est
la leçon étrangère des états unis de
l'allemagne de la suède et plus les gens
sont formés puissant qualifiés et plus
facilement il trouve à l'emploi mais ce
soit sur une dernière question un peu
plus politique c'est là vous êtes on le
sait l'un des ministres de l'ouverture
on vous dit toujours proche de raymond
barre al'approche des municipales la
stratégie je dirais de décentrage et de
rapprochement avec le parti communiste
affiché à la fois par michel rocard et
le ps est ce que ça ne vous met pas un
peu en porte-à-faux un peu mal à l'aise
non match et j'ai indiqué que la
majorité et était vaste et diverse et
que
chaque ville doit pouvoir trouver sa
solution et sa solution adaptée il y
aura donc des listes je le comprends qui
uniront au premier tour les socialistes
et les communistes mais permettez moi de
dire qu' il peut y avoir aussi d'autres
cas où il ya des 10 qui permettront à
des centristes il ya des socialistes de
se présenter ensemble il ya des lices
comme c'est à dire une serre comme celle
d'auxerre où je ferais autour d'un
programme qui sera défini avec les
responsables économiques et sociaux de
sa ville de cette ville l'union la plus
large pour auxerre monsieur soissons
merci bons sondages pour michel rocard
après son navy son émission télévisée de
dimanche dernier
selon le quotidien de demain 63% des
personnes interrogées estiment qu'il est
un premier ministre compétent 19%
pensent le contraire
74 % sont favorables à une loi sur le
service minimum même si les syndicats
ils sont hostiles plus de grévistes à la
ratp mais trois lignes étaient encore
fermés aujourd'hui il faudra quelques
jours avant que le trafic redevienne
complètement normal fin de la grève au
tri postal de marseille 17 millions de
plis 17 millions de plis et colis ont
été bloqués en 37 jours de conflit il
faudra une dizaine de jours pour
résorber le retard
et puis grève des employés d'autoroute
pendant ce week-end de grands départs en
vacances mais là probablement en s'en
plaindra patron rien ne va plus entre
paris et la commission de bruxelles
roger fauroux le ministre de l'industrie
a pas convaincu le commissaire européen
chargé de la concurrence qui estime que
la décision française d'alléger de 12
milliards de francs
les dettes publiques de la régie renault
impose au moins un changement de statut
les explications de nicolas jacobs ce
sera sur le gouvernement l'ultime touche
de finition un coup d'épongé sur 12
milliards de francs de dettes
la régie a certes retrouvé le chemin des
profits 6 milliards cette année mais son
endettement est telle que si elle était
une entreprise classique elle serait
malgré tout en faillite
ces 12 milliards doivent lui permettre
de retrouver l'équilibré financier
mais bruxelles veille sur la libre
concurrence d'accord pour cette aide de
l'état mais à une seule condition que ce
soit vraiment là dernier
et pour en être sûr renault doit changer
de statut juridique
l'initiateur de ce projet alain madelin
avait d'ailleurs proposé de transformer
la régie en société anonyme
il n'en est plus question répond son
successeur roger fauroux qui aujourd'hui
choisi de passer outre le veto de
bruxelles
chardonnay les 2 milliards à renault
parce que renault 1 a besoin pour son
expansion et que l'état doit faire son
devoir d'actionnaire
il va falloir maintenant beaucoup de
souplesse à paris et bruxelles pour
dénouer la crise en tout état de cause
le gouvernement français ne veut pas
entendre parler de renault société
anonyme
la régie est un symbole dit-on à manier
avec précaution le projet de loi créant
le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel a
été adoptée aujourd'hui par l'assemblée
sans vote ni motion de censure puisque
le gouvernement avait engagé une
nouvelle fois sa responsabilité le rpr
et l'udf ont aussitôt saisi le conseil
constitutionnel qui devra maintenant
situé sur l'orthodoxie du projet ce qui
va retarder son entrée en application
m lambard inculpé hier dans le cadre de
la sphère camps sont sous contrôle
judiciaire après paiement d'une caution
d'un million de francs and gas burget m
lombard sous contrôle judiciaire 24
heures après son inculpation l'avocat
marseillais s'est vu retirer son
passeport il devra en outre verser une
caution d'un million de francs et se
présenter au moins une fois par semaine
au commissariat
le juge bernard chargé de l'instruction
la ferc ans on se donne donc la liberté
de convoquer à tout moment paul lombard
défendu par m e kiejman inculpé de recel
et complicité de faux en écriture m
lombard est soupçonné d'avoir servi
d'intermédiaire pour une vente de toiles
entre la fosse héritière de madame de
pensants et le musée du louvre le juge
s'est donné jusqu'au 12 janvier pour
démêler la faire d'ici là et mieux même
s'il garde le droit de plaider maître
lambard est interdit de conseil en
affaires
le bébé s'appelle vincent la maman elle
fut en son temps plus connu sous le
qualificatif de faux époux thuringe
capitaine officier de la dgse
madame prieur à la ville vient donc de
donner naissance à un petit garçon
dominique prieur que l'on voit ici à son
retour du pacifique avait été condamné à
dix ans de prison puis assigné à
résidence
pour 3 ans sur l'atoll d'hao par la
justice néo-zélandaise sa grossesse lui
avait permis de revenir en france en
avril 87 un mois de prison avec sursis
3000 francs d'amande six mois de
suspension permis c'est le prix que
devra payer sacha distel pour avoir
manqué un virage en avril 85 dans la
nièvre
le tribunal correctionnel de nevers a
suivi les réquisitions du procureur qui
mettait en cause la maîtrise du chanteur
au volant un accident dans lequel
chantal nobel avait été gravement blessé
trois ans après la comédienne toujours
pas réapparu
ses avocats ont estimé que sacha distel
avait été jugée comme monsieur tout le
monde
le chanteur a décidé de faire appel ce
soir à 22h15 sur antenne 2 le magazine
résistance est consacrée à l'afghanistan
l'afghanistan où la guerre oubliée dans
la tente d'un retrait des troupes
soviétiques
les moudjahidine continuent de se battre
pour tenter de reconquérir les villes
c'est ce que jérôme baugnies et
jean-françois hoffman ont vu près de
fayzabad au nord-est du pays
avec le retrait des troupes soviétiques
les moudjahidine s'empare des villes
moyennes mais ils ont du mal à assurer
la défense des populations contre des
bombardiers venu directement d'union
soviétique
en revanche leurs prises de guerre sont
engagés dans la bataille des métropoles
régionales dans le badakhchan fayzabad
pour le régime actuel il est vital que
les grandes villes tienne car leur chute
ce sont des moudjahidines et leur butin
qui se retourne contre kaboul
autour de faïza bad les missiles
antiaériens permettent de maintenir les
mig à une altitude où ils sont peu
opérationnels résultat les moudjahidine
peuvent aujourd'hui attaqué en plein
jour dans le collimateur la garnison de
fayzabad où sont repliés 10000
gouvernementaux souvent sympathisants
d'un mouvement maoïste peu implanté dans
le reste du pays
paradoxalement ces maoïstes vont
recevoir des projectiles de fabrication
chinoise
dès le deuxième tir
c'est larry paul ajoie résolu surprise
abad et les réponses des troupes
gouvernementales sont immédiates
elles répondent avec des orgues de
staline et pilonnent les positions des
moudjahidine proches comme zola
pourtant ça certains projectiles touche
aussi des habitations y compris
peut-être les maisons des cousins ou des
frères des attaquants l'afghanistan la
guerre de 9 ans ce soir à résistance
espoir d'une libération rapide de
jacqueline valente de ses trois
petites-filles et des cinq belges
détenus avec elle au liban c'est ce que
le ministre des affaires étrangères
roland dumas à signifie tout à l'heure à
la mère et au beau frère de jeunes
femmes qui étaient nos invités avanthier
et qui vous savez portes samedi pour
beyrouth départ de beyrouth de
l'ambassadeur de suisse et du personnel
de l'ambassade
un départ qui suit celui des délégués de
la croix rouge internationale israël
enfin un gouvernement depuis cet
après-midi un gouvernement de coalition
élargie martine laroche-joubert
on prend les mêmes et on recommence il
sa famille et shimon perez ont signé ce
matin un nouvel garde-corps de
gouvernement d'union nationale les
religieux acceptent de strapontins l'un
de taille il est vrai le ministère de
l'intérieur
l'investiture a été votée cet après midi
au parlement israélien
ils s'abstenir a déjà présenté le point
fort de son programme pas de dialogue
avec l'ol paie
algérie des élections sans surprise le
président chadli candidat unique du fln
est certain d'être ré restait un point
d'interrogation le taux de participation
s'est gagné plus de 70 % de votants le
président chadli dispose donc d'une
légitimité suffisante pour imposer la
nouvelle politique d'ouverture dont ils
se réclament
la dernière colonie d'afrique
indépendante le sort de la namibie a été
réglé ce matin en échange du départ de
50 mille soldats cuba d'angola l'accord
a été signé aux nations unies entre la
puissance coloniale depuis 1915
l'afrique du sud l'angola et cuba le
processus d'indépendance démarrera le
1er avril 1989 avec la bénédiction des
états unis
ça bouge en pologne devant le dixième
plenum du parti ouvrier polonais le
nouveau premier ministre à côte ce qui
n'a pas ménagé ses compliments à l'aise
valises à celui ci jadis ennemi
implacable du socialisme est devenu un
homme de compromis pondérer avec lequel
il est possible de s'entendre les mots
semblent en accord avec les faits les
instances suprêmes du parti ont été
remaniés les réformateurs gagne du
terrain
si vous aimez à la fois la sculpture et
le bricolage le fil de fer et les grands
ensembles
ne manquez pas la rétrospective que le
centre beaubourg à paris consacre en ce
moment à tinguely caire champetier nous
fait découvrir le suisse et ses drôles
de machines
ding lié suisse les roues et les pignons
il a ça dans le sang
il fait grincer l'humour dans les
rouages qui anime son monde public
réjouis-toi toutes ces machines plus de
300 fonctionneront en permanence sous la
surveillance de deux dépanneurs suisse
bien sûr ça tape ça frotte ça saute sa
requête sa crainte sa rampe ça se
trémousse ça se tortille ont fini par se
sentir soi même un peu déglingué
lézat apprécieront le côté charlot de
tinguely
je parle bien sûr du charlot des temps
modernes les autres aimeront le côté
débridé le burlesque anar la provocation
de ces petits jésus style tournicoti
tournicoton moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
le sourire fantastique la compassion
effrayante de tous ces crânes de
bestiaux qui tricotent des mandibules
avec des bénédictions infernale et vous
savez où il est allé chercher tout ça
dans les poubelles
ce qui est étrange avec l'art c'est que
ça peut à la fois valoir de l'or est pas
un clou ils sont mus les pieds pétrifié
classifiés culture y fier je suis à
l'artiste extrémistes se cache peut-être
est excellent et en faisant réussir une
chose extrêmes on en lui toujours tout
le monde on en met les assureurs
on avait les transferts on ennuie les
musées quand les portes pillent
on en rit énormément de gens rang
connais au moins un qui est bien ennuyé
c'est jean-yves moque l'organisateur il
n'a jamais vu une exposition consommer
autant d'électricité
il n'a qu'une crainte c'est que tinguely
face aux télés plomb la vie encore les
rapports du quinté de vincennes
aujourd'hui à l'arrivée vous le voyez le
neuf le 11 le 3 et le 15 5 francs dans
l'ordre rapporte 300 8334 francs et dans
un ordre différent 25600 4 94 30 50
voilà à 22h10 donc résistance avec noël
mamère et jérôme bunny que vous
retrouverez dans un instant sophie
davant vous parlera du temps de demain
notre dernier journal tout à l'heure
avec henri sannier demain invités de
gérard morin aux 4 vérités
abdelhamid mehri le secrétaire général
du fln en direct d'alger à l'occasion de
l'élection présidentielle algérienne qui
a eu lieu donc aujourd'hui voilà quand à
moi je fasse demain le relais à hervé
claude je vous souhaite
très bon noël est une excellente année
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver en
merci à toi